(bright upbeat music)
Certain species of sea life
like the bowhead whale, large mammal can live for 200 years.
And Greenland sharks can live 400 or 500 years.
And so the question is, if they can live that long,
why can't we?
(gentle upbeat music)
It's either gonna a hardware problem or a software problem,
and we're gonna have the tools to fix that.
And I think, we're on the precipice of that.
(bright upbeat music)
I'm seeing what's going on in all of these different fields.
And I have zero question
about reaching longevity escape velocity.
Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today, we continue a conversation
that has been ongoing for some time on this podcast
around the subject matter of health span extension
and the fascinating emerging science and technology
of longevity.
My guest for this exploration is Peter Diamandis.
Peter is a graduate of MIT in Harvard Medical School.
He's perhaps best known
as the founder and executive chairman
of the XPRIZE Foundation,
as well as being the executive founder
of Singularity University.
Peter was named by Fortune
as one of the world's 50 greatest leaders.
Over the course of his career,
he started over 20 companies in the areas of longevity,
space, venture capital, and education.
He's also a New York Times bestselling author.
And his latest book,
which he co-wrote with Tony Robbins is entitled,
"Life Force."
And that book provides the framework for today's discussion
about the future of healthcare,
the emerging science of life extension,
and the philosophical implications of all of this.
In addition, we talk about the evolutionary implications
of self-aware artificial intelligence,
we discuss the future of education,
also the importance of mindset
in solving our biggest problems,
as well as this pivotal role
in the growth of privatized space exploration.
And let's not forget, why he thinks bringing back
the woolly mammoth is a good idea.
Suffice it to say,
we cover a variety of fascinating ground in this one,
I really enjoyed Peter's company.
So please hit that subscribe button.
And here you go.
This is me and Peter Diamandis.
Peter, it's so nice to meet you.
Thank you for doing this.
I followed your work for quite some time.
I'm excited to meet you and talk to you.
There's so many threads that we can pull today.
And I think just as an introductory note,
the way that I think about you
is as somebody who's made a name for himself
being somebody who's all about big bold ideas,
moonshot thinking,
and how to kind of disrupt this disruptive approach
to solving or approaching and solving
the world's biggest problems
and reimagining a better future for humanity.
And you've got your tentacles in tons of stuff.
I think today, we're gonna focus on probably
our shared favorite subject,
which is health and extending health span.
Before we get into anything though,
I gotta know what's in your...
You came here today with a big green smoothie.
You got it in front of you there,
I need to know what's in that.
Athletic green, so I do an intermittent fast every day
through till about 2, 2:30,
and I'll drink some athletic greens just to flavor the water
and give me a little bit of extra benefit.
There you go.
Big supporter of the podcast.
I'm a big fan of athletic.
I had mine this morning as well, so good to know.
Cheers.
You've got this new book out, "Life Force"
that you co-authored with Tony Robbins.
So I wanna dig into healthcare, the future of healthcare,
health span, longevity, and all of that.
But I think to begin,
it's probably worth just canvasing
the current state of healthcare and how you think about it
as a basis point
for how we're going to disrupt this broken system,
and reimagine a better, newer one.
Yeah, it's completely ridiculous.
It's a system that deserves to die under its own weight.
And just like Google disrupted libraries,
and like when's the last time you went to a library,
and then provided ubiquitous access to information,
we're gonna see the same thing happen in healthcare.
And it's really going to be
not the existing healthcare companies
that make the transition,
it's gonna be a flock of new ones.
And the healthcare companies of the future
may sound like Amazon and Google and Microsoft
and others, Apple, to add to the list.
It's really gonna be the convergence
of these exponential technologies,
convergence of AI, and sensor technologies,
and synthetic biology, and quantum computing.
One of the things I'm clear about is this decade,
we're gonna see healthcare move out of the hospitals,
out of the doctor's office, into your home, onto your body.
And it's gonna become,
what has historically been a reactive generic system.
I mean, you know the numbers as well as I do
that when you have an FDA approved drug
that you've been given to take,
you think it's gonna work for you,
but it works for like 10% to 20% of the people
it's prescribed for.
It just may not be working with you, your physiology,
your genomics, your microbiome, and so forth.
And the potential is a completely personalized,
completely preventative and predictive model
where the recommendations
I'm getting from the healthcare AI,
it's about making yourself the CEO of your own health.
I think about that.
I think about Jarvis from Ironman, that AI,
that Ironman has really
continuously measuring my biology
from sensors I'm wearing that are implanted,
that are in my bed or the chair,
that's measuring exactly what's going on all the time
and giving me recommendations.
This is the future of healthcare.
This is where we're going.
And it's a future of healthcare,
which like Google is demonetized and democratized.
It's gonna be the best healthcare ever.
And it's gonna be the lowest cost healthcare
available to everybody.
The democratization aspect of it though,
only comes in time as most of these things go,
they begin very expensive in that early stage.
And that's sort of a hurdle that has to be addressed.
But I mean, currently,
when you look at our healthcare system,
particularly in the United States,
it's sort of sinking under the bloat
of its bureaucratic morass,
and it's a situation in which
we're dealing with human beings at the late stages
of whatever's ailing them.
You don't go to the doctor unless something's wrong
with the exception of the occasional check in or whatever,
which is fine,
but we're dealing with all of these conditions
once they have progressed and matured to a certain point,
and then it becomes a situation
in which the doctor is diagnosing and prescribing
a medical intervention
that oftentimes at least, pharmaceutically
is treating a symptom and not the underlying condition.
And with the advent of these technologies,
it seems to me, a lot of this has to do with early detection
at the very outset of these situations,
so that they can be addressed,
because once they've crossed a certain threshold
and matured to a certain point,
they become almost impossible to untangle or reverse.
Catch cancer at stage zero or stage one,
you've got a 95% to 99% chance of a complete cure.
Catch it at stage three, or God forbid, stage four,
your chance of a cure is down to like 10%.
And we're all developing cancers all the time,
I think that's something that people would understand
that is the normal course of what's going on in biology,
but we have our immune systems
that find the cancer and zap it
before it gets uncontrollable.
And it's when your immune system gets exhausted
or your cancer has certain tricks to hide itself
from your immune system,
that it can get out of control.
And yeah, it's about early diagnosis.
And one of the things I'd like to talk with you about,
if not now and a little bit later in our conversation
is the incredible progress in diagnostic technologies.
I just went two days ago for my annual health upload.
And this is not like,
listen to your lungs and your heart and tap your knee
and prostate exam.
No, this is undigitized,
on your 50 gigabytes of data about me,
full body MRI, brain MRI, brain vasculature,
and AI-enabled coronary CT.
So we're using a platform called Clearly,
that is looking for soft plaque, not calcified plaque.
If it's calcified, it's safe, it's not gonna rupture,
it's like cemented into the wall.
And if it's not including the coronary artery, that's fine.
But if it's soft plaque that can rupture and block,
that's where it's dangerous.
And the old CTs don't find that, Clearly does.
And so, that I do every year,
which is brand new technology
that we've got at Fountain Life.
I did it a year ago and I had a really good score.
It wasn't perfect.
I put some interventions in place
and it's my cardiac status
has significantly improved in a year,
but I can measure that.
And that gives me inspiration to keep going.
Then we do, part of this upload is your genome,
your microbiome, your full blood omics.
We do a Grail liquid biopsy test.
Tell me what is that?
So, Grail, a guy named Jeff Huber
who was a senior VP at Google, beautiful guy.
His wife was diagnosed with breast cancer,
was probably stage three, might have been stage four
when it was too late, and she passed.
And being the entrepreneur he was,
he said, there's gotta be something better we can do.
We've gotta be able to find these cancers in the body.
So he partnered with a group within Illumina,
which is the major sequencing company out there.
And developed what's called the liquid biopsy.
And so, when a cancer is growing at someplace in your body,
you don't know where it is,
it's dividing and cells rupture,
and the DNA from those cancer cells
becomes accessible in your bloodstream.
And so Grail is a blood test you take
and it looks for 50 different cancer markers
in your bloodstream.
And depending on how old you are,
because the frequency of cancer is increasing,
it's a test you do, today, I do it once a year,
eventually, I'll do it every six months,
who knows, maybe even a quarter,
it's relatively low cost compared to the expenses.
And so, if you detect a cancer,
you're then beginning to look,
and the full body MRI will show that to you as well.
So for me, it's like a forest fire.
When you wanna put the forest fire out
when it's at ignition or when it's in it's configuration?
Right, so right now, when we think about
the sort of things that we should all be doing
on a daily basis, there's a lot of low hanging fruit.
A hundred percent.
It's like-
Gets you to the basics.
It's something we talk about all the time.
Yeah, it's sleep, nutrition, exercise, reduce your stress,
mindfulness practices, community,
sort of finding purpose in your life,
all of these sorts of things.
And then beyond that, we start to venture into this terrain
that is in your Bailiwick.
And I've had some of your colleagues on the show,
Matthew Walker to talk about sleep.
I've had David Sinclair on a couple of times,
and you've gone down that rabbit hole
of the emerging science,
and then Sergey Young
who as you know 'cause you work with him,
his book just paints this wild picture of the future.
We're at the very early stages of this
where we're wearing aura rings and whoop.
And we have, yeah, like all that kind of stuff.
But this is just very nascent in terms of what's to come.
So I wanna get into some of these emerging technologies
in a little bit more detail.
That's the fun part.
Why don't we, yeah...
And then I have some philosophical
kind of thought experiment questions
that I wanna throw your way.
But let's talk about where we're at,
and what's to come with respect to things like genomics,
AI, sensor tech, 3D printing, and the like.
Sure, sure.
I mean, let me just say
that the basics are still critically important.
Sure, I mean, in the pyramid of everything,
like you're not gonna get away with much
if you're not taking care of those things, right?
A hundred percent.
So I feel a moral obligation
to tell people a few basic things,
which are the same things that you've talked about
and written about in your career.
Sleep is fundamental.
Matt Walker, UC Berkeley, brilliant thinker here.
He wrote a great book called, "Why We Sleep."
I commend it amazingly.
And if evolution could have gotten rid
of a single hour of sleep,
the advantage of a subpopulation of humans
that slept seven hours versus eight hours is huge.
It hasn't, we need eight hours of sleep.
And I used to brag when I was in medical school
about being good on five or five and a half hours.
Now I'm bragging about hitting eight hours every night
and do that with a great eye mask,
or about taking the temperature down to 64 degrees,
having a cooling mattress
and really getting asleep at 9:30 and waking up at 5:30,
just like consistency.
And not watching TV.
I actually put on an audible book with a timer
to go off in 15 minutes
to get to read a bedtime story.
On diet, again, fundamental
for me, it's a whole plant diet.
I've gone vegan, I've gone keto.
I'm back to sort of a whole plant
with some Mediterranean sort of fish and eggs,
and then intermittent fasting
for 18 hours and then eat for six.
You do that every day?
Every day, yeah.
Well, let me just say,
I do cheat occasionally with the kids on a Saturday morning,
but I try not to.
Yeah, and it's interesting,
when you are doing intermittent fasting,
I have incredible amount of energy.
And people would think,
well, I need the food to fuel me and so forth.
When I eat food after I've been fasting,
it pulls the blood into your digestive system.
And it makes you lethargic like on Thanksgiving day.
And then of course, exercise, fundamental
again, you know more about that than I do.
But I try and take almost every meeting I possibly can
as a walking meeting,
or a walking phone call, or a walking Zoom.
So I try and get my 10,000 steps in a day.
And then, I do a heavy weight workout twice a week
and lightweights the other days.
Yeah, well you look great.
You're like, you're 60?
I'm 60, I feel like I have a mental image of 28.
And there is that,
I mean, David Sinclair talks about the difference
between the biological clock
and the kind of,
what does he call?
Chronological and biological.
Yeah, so where are you on that scale?
So, yeah David, when we wrote our book, "Life Force,"
we say David Sinclair is two ages,
he's chronologically 53, and his biological age was 33.
He was like, holy cow, that's amazing.
I'm 60 and 49 and a half.
And so, I'm gonna keep trying to get it down
as far as I can.
And where are you at
in terms of some of the Sinclair protocol
with the NMN and the Metformin and rapamycin
and all of that kind of stuff?
'cause it seems like there's some debate.
Yeah, there's an ongoing debate
as to the veracity of all of that.
So I'm all in.
No, actually, I'm probably a 9 out of 10.
I'm not a toe in person.
So I jump and then figure out how to build a parachute.
So where am I on that regard?
I've got, I'm taking probably about 50 supplements a day.
I do a monogram of Metformin.
Metformin is a very cheap medicine.
It is a medicine, your prescription for it.
And it's also known by the name Glucophage
and it reduces access to glucose
in the bloodstream and the cells,
it's thought to impact the mitochondria.
It's one of the safest drugs out there.
It appears, there's a large study
that Dr. Nir Barzilai at Einstein Medical School
is working on right now,
that Metformin from the data he's looked, extends your life,
it reduces the prevalence of cancer,
and has got very low impact.
I'm then taking a number of other supplements
from Quercetin to turmeric.
Antioxidants, anti-inflammatories.
And I'm supplementing my testosterone.
I think that's a really important thing
that people need to realize,
our bodies were never designed to live past age 30.
On the Savannahs of Africa, a hundred thousand years ago,
you'd go into puberty at age 12 or 13,
and you were pregnant by age 13 or 14,
and then by the time you were 28, your kid was having a kid.
Yeah, grandparents in their twenties.
And the worst thing you could do
to perpetuate the species,
was steal food from the mouths of your grandchildren.
And so you would die.
You'd give your bits back to the environment.
And so there was no selective pressure
to keep you in homeostasis
in your forties, fifties, or sixties,
'cause you had done your deed, you had reproduced already.
And as a result, we go out of homeostasis.
Our pituitary, our hormonal levels are all decreasing
and it is possible.
And I think the right thing to do
to optimize your testosterone levels.
And the challenge is that different kinds of physicians
have different sense of what's normal.
So you might not have your doctor
suggest testosterone supplementation
until your testosterone level is down below 200 or 150,
where you probably wanted to be
in the 500 to 800 or a 1000 level
to really have the vitality and energy to build muscle,
to have clarity of thought.
So I take 0.2 ml injection subq twice a week.
And I've thought about rapamycin.
I have not started on that.
Fountain Life, which I mentioned,
which does all the diagnostics,
has a regenerative medicine side as well.
And we're working with the Buck Institute
on trials and in investigation new drug around rapamycin,
around stem cells, around Dasatinib and Quercetin.
These are this senolytic medicines out there.
And there's a lot of data coming in,
it's the early day still.
But this decade is gonna be magical.
Yeah, how long before you think we reach
what you've talked about
as achieving longevity escape velocity,
maybe like describe what that is?
So today, science is having breakthroughs
that are extending your life every year.
And on the average, for every year you're alive,
science extends your life for about a quarter of a year.
There is a point and Ray Kurzweil
talks about it extensively.
And Ray wrote the preface of our book.
He's one of my mentors,
one of the greatest thinkers on exponential technologies.
He's my co-founder at Singularity University.
And I asked him, when do you think
we're gonna reach longevity escape velocity,
which is the point that for every year you're alive,
science is extending your life for greater than a year.
Sort of a departure point.
And his answer about when we'll get there,
he said is about 12 years.
That's his guess.
Now, if someone else said it,
I wouldn't give it that much credence.
But if you Google, Ray Kurzweil's
accuracy on his predictions, it's like 86%.
I mean, the guy is extraordinary
in his predictions of the future.
And then, I was in a conversation with George Church
who else write about extensively in the book.
And I asked George, when do you think we're gonna,
George is a professor of genomics at Harvard Medical School,
same as David Sinclair.
They're fantastic friends and collaborators.
And George said, within the next 15 years.
And so, I'm like, that's kind of insane.
Right, let's assume for a moment that that's correct.
15 years from now, give or take,
we'll be able to,
every year that you live,
there will be an incremental-
(indistinct) of life span.
Yeah, sufficient enough,
such that the perpetuation of life
would seem to never cease.
Yeah, it's like,
we have a 24,000 mile diameter
or circumference of the planet.
And if you're in a jet
going at a thousand miles an hour Westward,
the sun never sets.
And that is,
and if you go faster, the sun will rise.
You're in stasis.
And so, it's somewhat similar in that regard.
And it gets you thinking,
which is, to use a phrase from one of Ray's books,
"Fantastic Voyage,"
it's living long enough to live forever.
Now, let's put aside the idea of living forever as a moment,
but how long can we live?
When I was in medical school years ago, Rich,
I remember watching a TV show on "Long Lived Sea Life."
And I didn't have much time for TV.
I would basically just watch Star Trek, whenever I could,
which was my sort of vitamin dosage.
And what I learned was that
certain species of sea life,
like the bowhead whale, large mammal,
can live for 200 years.
And Greenland sharks can live 400 or 500 years.
Sea turtles, similar, multi-hundred year lifespan.
And so the question is if they can live that long,
why can't we?
And I remember thinking,
it's either gonna be a hardware problem
or a software problem,
and we're gonna have the tools to fix that.
And I think we're on the precipice of that.
And from a philosophical point of view,
like that conjures up a conversation
around the appropriateness of all of it, does it not?
I mean, you're somebody who's always been very optimistic.
You've written a couple of books
where you kind of canvas these emerging technologies
and you characterize them in very favorable terms.
So you're not one to be prone to dystopian scenarios.
But I can't help but think like in the event
that perhaps, we could live to something like 200 years,
like what would that mean?
Like how does that impact our psychology as a species?
How does it impact how we think about risk?
How does that impact overpopulation
on a planet of decreasingly limited resources, et cetera?
So how are you wrapping your head around all of that?
I know you got a whole thing.
Let's open the story, I love it.
So first of all, a study came out six months ago
done by Lang School of Business, Oxford and Harvard
that looked at the impact of extending the lifespan
by just one year of every human on the planet.
The economic impact is $38 trillion global economy
of being able to keep you and me in the game a year longer.
So it's a massive, positive impact to the global economy,
earning potential, being productive.
Now the question about overpopulation,
and I write about that
in the chapter on exponential tech and longevity.
And a lot of people are concerned
about overpopulation of planet earth.
Then there's a lot of people, including myself,
Elon Musk, I had this conversation with him last April.
They're concerned about massive under population
of planet earth.
I have a hard time seeing that being a reality.
Well, look at the numbers.
So 50 years ago,
the average was 5.7 children per family globally.
Today, that has dropped to 2.4 children per family globally.
Replacement level is 2.1.
The idea being when you raise the floor
on economic wellbeing and you increase access to education,
the number of kids goes down.
Significantly.
And so, the US is below the replacement level.
Most of Europe is below replacement level.
Japan, China, below the replacement level.
And the concern is
that rather than going out with a bang,
it's gonna be a whimper that we're gonna peak.
And we will peak just like peak oil and peak natural gas
and all those other scarcity mindset.
We're gonna peak at nine, nine and a half billion people,
and then a very rapid decline.
And the numbers post COVID
is that the reproduction rate
has dropped precipitously post COVID.
So we talk about the great resignation
and having difficulty finding people, which is true.
I'm involved in a dozen companies
and hiring people is getting harder and harder.
I'm gonna want to keep people in the game.
And why do people stop working?
Because they're in pain or they're tired,
they don't have the energy.
And so, but if you can have the vitality,
the aesthetics, the cognition, the mobility,
at a hundred years old that you had at 50 or 60,
it's amazing time to be alive.
I can't help, but think, if you could live to 200,
the possibility certainly exists
that you would have multiple partners
across that period of time.
And you might have multiple families.
Like I had a whole family with two kids with this person,
and now I'm gonna have two kids with this,
you could do that three or four times over.
And multiple careers, three or four times over.
The reality is that our existence,
our societal structure, our laws,
are built around a very different age.
We don't have a true democracy of a representative democracy
'cause the communications didn't exist back
hundreds of years ago
to be able to count everybody's vote,
but they do now.
And the idea of social security
was designed and developed
when the average lifespan was like 55.
You would retire, go on social security,
18 months later you were dead.
And so, all of this is changing.
For the financial advisors listening to us
or the people who are dependent upon financial advisors,
making sure you have enough money,
if you're gonna add 20 or 30 healthy years
is an important conversation to have.
And it's not being heard sufficiently.
'Cause I think, this is the direction that we're heading.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know,
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is,
the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH@checkout.
This is life changing stuff,
people for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code, RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
It's also interesting to think about
how we calibrate risk also,
because if you're faced
with the prospect of living that long,
how do you think about like,
oh, am I gonna play football in high school?
Am I gonna go skydiving?
Like why would you incur any unnecessary risk
that could threaten your ability
to live for another century?
There's a great science fiction story called
"The Puppet Masters."
I think it's by Larry Nevin or David Brin.
And it's a society
that has achieved longevity escape velocity.
And they got to a point where they're so risk averse,
they have no corners on their tables.
They don't wanna like bump themselves.
And I think...
It's hard to anticipate
what that psychological makeup would be,
because we have no experience with something like that.
I think the single most important thing
around the psychological makeup of longevity
is having purpose long enough,
enough of having a bigger future for yourself
than your past.
To keep you wanting to stay in the game,
that keeps you excited for
there's probably a great French term,
the V day, whatever.
That keeps you excited about.
Like for me, Rich, as you know my early passions in life
were all space.
It was the "Apollo Program," it was "Star Trek."
It was all of that stuff.
And it's just now,
and I worked for 20 plus years
in the commercial space industry.
It's just now through the work that mostly Elon's doing,
and to some degree Jeff Bezos
and Richard Branson and others
that we're opening the space frontier.
I want to go and walk on the moon, start a city there.
I want to go and mine the asteroids.
I want to see that future.
But unless I'm able to tack on
an extra 30 healthy years of my life,
it's gonna be just out of reach.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, it is worth mentioning,
in talking about private spacecraft
and everything that we're seeing going on right now,
which is unbelievable,
that it really all tracks back to your initial XPRIZE.
Like everything that we're seeing in the private space
with space exploration, I don't, would it have happened,
had you not created that initial XPRIZE?
I mean, maybe it would have,
but it was really an inflection point for this whole thing.
Thank you, it was like, when I grew up,
my parents were both in medical field.
My dad both born in Lesbos.
So my dad came over, became an OB-GYN.
My mom should have been a doctor,
she managed the office for him,
and it was always expected, I become a doctor.
That was it, it was like, it is like that old joke
around the presence being inaugurated
and his mom is there and the person goes,
"Mrs. so and so, aren't you so proud of your son,
"he's become the president?"
She goes, "Yes,
"but you see that guy next to him,
"that's his brother, and he's a doctor."
It was like that kind of a thing.
And so, space captured my heart
and I wanted so desperately to become an astronaut.
And so I went to medical school,
if I wasn't a fighter pilot,
being a medical doctor was the next highest probability
of being an astronaut core.
And I got to meet lots of astronauts.
I did research on them, befriended many of them,
the Apollo astronauts, the Shuttle astronauts.
And what I learned really boggled my mind.
First of all,
my chances of becoming a NASA astronaut
like one in a thousand.
I'm 5'4 and a half, I'll add the half there.
And my chance of becoming a NASA astronaut,
I have more of a chance becoming NBA all-star than I do.
It's like, it's crazy.
Half the astronauts selected in the core have never flown,
they're called penguins
'cause they have wings and they don't fly.
And then, if you do get to fly,
on the average at most, it's two flights during your career.
And I'm like, that's just not my vision of going to space.
I wanna go like every weekend if I want to go.
And so I made a wholesale shift to commercial space,
and really began focused on
how do I open it up commercially?
How do I build a business
an exothermic economic reaction?
Started something called International Space University,
started at a company I'm very fond of called Zero-G.
With Ray.
Yeah, with Ray.
Ray Kurzweil, myself and Byron Lichtenberg
co-founded that, the three of us.
And it took us 11 years to get approval
from the FAA to do that.
But our highlight was flying Stephen Hawking
into Zero-G, world's expert in gravity
and the weightlessness.
It was amazing.
I remember that.
And then I was given a copy of the Spirit of St. Louis
Lindbergh's biography by a dear friend, Gregg Maryniak.
And I'm reading this book in the Chronicles,
something called the Orteig Prize.
It was a $25,000 prize offered in 1919
for the first person to fly between New York and Paris.
And it was considered craziness.
The idea you can fly that distance.
And nine teams went after this $25,000 prize.
Four of them died in making the attempt.
And Lindberg who was the most unlikely guy to do it,
had been flying only for two years.
No one would sell him an airplane or an engine,
'cause they were so scared that he would fail
and give them a bad reputation.
He makes the flight 33 and a half hours
from a Roosevelt field to Le Bourget.
Becomes the most famous humans on the planet,
aviation skyrockets.
And it was cause of that prize.
And I was like, that's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna create a prize.
And so I announced the idea of a $10 million prize
for the first team who could build a private spaceship,
carry three adults up to a hundred kilometers,
land and do it again within two weeks.
And lo and behold, we had 26 teams from seven countries,
guy named Burt Rutan,
who had built the Voyager airplane
that flew nonstop around the world,
backed by Microsoft co-founder, Paul Allen,
built SpaceShipOne and claimed the prize in 2004.
I think the legacy of that was one,
we had to change all the regulations
and that was a big deal.
The regulations for commercial private human space life
did not exist.
And we worked, we said, listen,
this price is gonna be won in Russia or Argentina.
So we got the laws changed here
and then most other countries copied as they do.
The FAA is usually the leader here.
Was that part of why it took that many years
or was it just the technological development?
No, it's the technology,
it was the capital that was required,
aggregating the capital to build these ships was,
'cause everybody said, listen,
can anyone really pull it off?
Why isn't NASA doing it?
And aren't you gonna die trying?
And so that just made it very risk averse for everybody.
And as a result of that,
it took eight years for the prize to get one.
Branson came in, bought the rights
to create Virgin Galactic.
And then I've known Jeff Bezos since college.
My first group ever was College Space Organization.
I was one of the MIT chapters, one of the present chapter.
'Cause you had this double life
through College and med school,
in the space world, starting all these organizations.
And then going through medical school
and trying to make my parents happy.
I remember I met with Bezos in Seattle
after like the year after he started Amazon
and I was like, "So Jeff,
"what up with Amazon?
"I thought you wanted to do space?"
And he goes, "Well, I'm gonna make my money in Amazon,
"then I'll go spend it in space."
Like a simple, two step plan.
Right, that clarity all the way back then.
Yeah and then he and Elon
who I've known through since 2000,
I was trying to get Elon to fund the Amir Ansari XPRISE
before I had the money and then the Ansari family funded it.
But this idea that you can inspire small teams
to do crazy things is huge.
And bringing this back to health and longevity,
working with David Sinclair and George Church,
we've designed and developed
and initially funded by Sergey Young to give him credit.
We've got an age reversal XPRISE
that we're very close to launching.
And when Sergey first went to do a longevity prize
and I've been the biggest longevity fan
involved in this industry for a decade now,
I was like, man,
I just don't see how we're gonna make an XPRISE out of it.
And the more I started studying it
and kudos to Sergey, I was like, oh, interesting.
And it was okay, we're not gonna do a longevity prize.
We're gonna do an age reversal prize
and it's can we...
And to win this prize,
you need to demonstrably
through a number of very specific mechanisms,
demonstrate the age reversal of three independent tissues
or organ systems in the human by 20 years or more
in a repeatable fashion.
Yeah, it's a pretty high bar,
especially when all of the,
it seems like all of the science right now
is in mice and rats and the like.
Yeah, it is.
That work is going from mice and rats into dogs.
And when I asked David and George
again, my two sort of superstars
and in the book "Life Force,"
we have these heroes and David and George
are definitive heroes in the book.
Ask them, when do you think we're gonna be seeing
the gene therapies
that were used to reverse the age in mice?
The answer is,
"We'll likely see it being tested in humans
"in five years time."
Which sounds insane.
Is that once again to kind of regulatory hurdles
or more about the progress of the science itself?
I think it's both, the FDA is a governor
like limiting the speed by virtue
of wanting to make sure it's done well
and doing it safely.
When I was in medical school and graduate school,
I was in a Richard Mulligan's Lab
at the Whitehead Institute at MIT in Harvard.
And it was the earliest days of gene therapy
and this incredibly brilliant man envision
of being able to use a virus in this case,
it had no associated virus,
that you've stripped out the virus's DNA
and put in the DNA that you want,
and using this virus to go and infect the specific cells
in the human body
and inject this piece of programming into it,
was a massively brilliant idea.
And unfortunately, when it was first tested,
it killed the young patient.
And it really set back the field
like five to 10 years,
I don't know the exact number.
And then it was eventually successfully trialed
in what's called bubble boy's disease
when you have no immune system.
And it was successful.
And now it's an extraordinary tool in the toolkit.
But you don't wanna make that mistake.
You don't want to have something set back the field.
So there's caution in doing it
in mice and rats and Guinea pigs and dogs and primates,
and then eventually humans.
Well, there's certainly a qualitative difference
between extending the life of cells, human cells
or decreasing the rate at which they decline.
And it's another thing altogether
to "reverse their aging."
So how do you demarcate the difference between those two?
So here's the question.
And it's one that when I first thought about it
and I'm not sure if I heard it posed
or just my mind came up with it,
which is when we're born,
we have 3.2 billion letters from our mother,
and 3.2 from our father,
and that same genome is there when we're 20 and 40
and 60 and 80 and a hundred.
And the question is if it's the same genome
and it is basically the same genome,
why do you look different?
What, why?
Then it turns out it's not your genome,
it's your epigenome.
Epi from the Greek word for above,
it's the controls of which genes are turned on
and which genes are turned off.
So as you well know,
every cell in our body has the genes
to become any other kind of cell in our body.
And when we begin life,
we are a pluripotent stem cell,
stemness means the ability to differentiate
into bone, muscle, ligament, whatever it might be.
But once it's differentiated,
that cell is only expressing the proteins for a muscle cell
or only expressing the proteins for a skin cell.
The other proteins that are used in the eye
or the brain or the liver are wrapped up
and tightly bound in this system
called our histones that limit it from being expressed.
And so it's why your cells
don't all of a sudden start becoming other types of cells.
You don't want,
sort of your muscle becoming skin cells
and that's your epigenome.
And what David Sinclair does a beautiful job
in his book "Lifespan," which I command to everybody
in discussing that our epigenome changes over time.
And you can measure your epigenome,
looking at methylation patterns,
the methyl groups of CH3
attached to different parts of your DNA
that control whether it can be red or not red,
and whether it's wrapped and tightly or not.
And he then goes on and talk about
what a system called a Sirtuin systems, right?
There are seven Sirtuin genes and seven Sirtuin proteins
that are controlling two different functions
that are critical to your existence.
One function that the sirtuins control is your epigenome.
The sirtuins are controlling,
keeping your muscle cell a muscle cell,
keeping your skin cell a skin cell.
The other thing that sirtuins are controlling is DNA repair.
So just living life, being hit by cosmic rays,
by chemicals in the environment, by secondhand smoke,
whatever it might be,
we're constantly being hit by these mutagens
that are causing double strand breaks
and single strand breaks
and other kinds of DNA damage.
The number I just read the other day
is a thousand to a million DNA hits per day per cell.
I mean, it's insane.
But luckily our cells have evolved
these DNA repair mechanisms.
And our Sirtuins are over seeing that
and supporting a DNA repair.
And as we get older,
the DNA repair is getting more and more burdensome
and it's distracting the sirtuins from their other function
of epigenetic regulation.
But it's even worse than that
because the fuel that sirtuins are using
is something called NAD.
And we can talk about NMN which is a precursor.
And as you age your NAD levels in your cells plummet
to under 50%,
again, in our forties, fifties, and sixties,
because our body was never designed to live that long.
There was no homoestasis at that point.
And so the way I visualize it in my mind
is your genome is like the keys of a piano.
Your epigenome is the piano player,
and if you're playing the right keys at the right time,
you're expressing yourself properly.
Now imagine that the piano player at the same time,
they're playing the concerto
need to go and repair this thing over here.
And the amount of time they're having to repair
is they're being distracted over and over
and more and more frequently.
And then imagine that the food that they're being fed
to energize them is getting less and less.
They're becoming weaker and weaker
and more and more distracted.
And so your epigenome gets dysregulated
and we then see skin changes, we see more cancer,
we see a whole slew of different age-related situations.
So the idea being that by ingesting
this exogenous NAD precursor in the form of NMN,
you're alleviating some of that burden
and allowing a better regulation.
You're giving your sirtuins more energy
to fight their good fight.
And what is the relationship between all of that
and this conversation around declining telomere lengths
and how that impacts our aging?
So I won't dive into areas
that I'm not fully sure about.
But I mean, telomeres are the end caps of our cells
that get shorter and shorter as we age.
So there's something called the hay flick limit,
which is your cells are able to replicate about 50 times.
And then they do one of three things.
After they've reached about 50 replications,
they should have the decency to die,
or if they don't, they could become cancer cells
and the regulatory breaks are taken off
and it can grow out of control.
And the third thing maybe that happens
is they become senile cells, also called zombie cells.
And they just sit there
and they produce inflammatory factors.
And I think the number is like 3% of our cells in our body
are senile cells.
In our skin, in our liver,
in our lungs and our kidneys.
And so there's a whole new set of medications
called senolytic medicines,
which are looking to identify
and zap those senile cells to kill them.
And the reason for that is if you're able to do that,
it reduces inflammation in the body,
which is one of the big cause of aging as well.
Right, that's Senescence.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go back to the Pluripotent cells, the stem cells.
I think what you're doing with Celularity
by capturing these cells in the form of the placenta
is pretty interesting.
Yeah, it's fascinating.
So one of our partners in the book is Dr. Bob Hariri
who's my older brother from another mother.
He's a pilot, he was a neurotrauma surgeon.
And early in his career when his wife was pregnant
with his daughter, Alex,
Bob found something curious
that normally when I was in medical school
and he was in medical school,
you're taught that the placenta
is sort of the support mechanism for the fetus.
And when he looked at his wife's echo was like,
it was clear the placenta was huge compared to the fetus
and like why, if it was a support mechanism
it should be growing at the same time.
Long story short,
he was the first person who really recognized
the placenta is the source of,
I think of it a 3D printer that manufactures the baby,
generates all of the cells, all the stem cells.
And when you have a baby,
typically the labor and delivery
will charge you to incinerate and get rid of the placenta.
And he said, instead of doing that,
we should be collecting this incredible organ
and collecting from it stem cells, exosomes,
natural killer cells, and T-cells
each for a different reason.
And he started doing this work as an entrepreneur,
got bought by a company called Celgene,
which is now part of Bristol Myers Squibb,
but Celgene was a hundred billion dollar company.
And Bob was running cellular medicine at Celgene.
About four or five years ago,
I helped him spin
what is now Celularity out of Celgene,
take the whole cellular medicine division out.
And we started this, Bob's chairman and CEO.
And I'm very proud to be vice chairman in the company.
And what Celularity does is a number of things.
Number one, we're the largest bank of placenta's
on the planet.
So when my wife and I had our two boys,
we banked their placenta's.
There's a company called LifebankUSA,
which is a division.
Anybody listening who is pregnant
or knows someone who's pregnant,
I think it's a more imperative to save the placenta.
Yeah, it's an insurance policy
out on your children's future.
Yeah, it's like,
that's the placental cells are like the original boot disk,
the original software.
And from that, you'll be able to have
so many benefits of regrowing organs,
or there's a whole series of cancer diseases
where you're gonna want to have access
to that original clean zero-day genome.
So Bob realized this,
and what Celularity is doing is it's doing,
it's mining the placenta for products.
So first thing is now natural killer cells.
And natural killer cells
are the part of your innate immune system
that can detect cancer and zap it.
Can detect cells infected by viruses and zap them.
And it turns out that in a mother who's pregnant,
who has cancer,
the probability of a cancer metastasizing to the child
is like near zero.
And it turns out that the natural killer cells
from the placenta find any cancer cells and zap them.
But when you're older as a human
and you have immune exhaustion, which occurs,
your immune system starts declining,
you don't have the ability to detect the cancer.
So what we do is we use the natural killer cells
from the placenta intravenously against a number of cancers.
We're now going into glioblastoma,
which is that terrible fatal brain disease.
And I can't discuss the results yet,
but we're super excited about this.
So natural killer cells and T-cells from placenta
as a supercharged, very vital youthful cancer mechanism.
And then stem cells,
as the means to augment your stem cells.
When you're born compared to age 80,
your stem cell populations are down like a hundred fold
or a thousand fold in different compartments.
And your stem cells are the regenerative engine of the body.
You can think of the body as a mansion
with a army of workers that support everything being right.
But as you age, the workers become senile, they die,
and the mansion starts falling apart.
Same thing for stem cells in your body.
So can you revitalize it?
In fact, this book "Life Force began.
Yes, 'cause Tony had this stenosis issue
right on his back.
Yeah, he was chasing a 22 year old skier,
what do you call it on the surfboard?
Snowboarding?
Snowboarder and trying to keep up.
And he takes a bad fall.
Buddy broke his neck,
had actually basically done a really bad rotator cuff.
And all of the surgeons were like,
"You need surgery, you need surgery, you need surgery.
And Tony is the guy that gets
the fifth, sixth and 10th opinion.
And he reached out to me one day and said,
"What do you think?"
And I said, "You should talk to Bob Hariri about stem cells.
And talking to Bob is like
asking someone to give you advice in basketball
and talking to LeBron James.
He's like the top of the game.
And so Bob advises him where to go get stem cell treatments.
And after three days, one shot in the shoulder
and three days of IVs, just for 30 minutes a day,
his pain is gone, his pain in his back is gone.
And a couple of months later his MRI is normal
and he's like this regenerative medicine stuff is amazing.
And results would vary.
And Tony is definitely a mind over matter kind of guy.
So if it's gonna work for anybody, it'll work for him.
And we began a journey.
So as part of the XPRISE,
I run an adventure trip every year for our benefactors.
And we were piggybacking at the Vatican
and running a longevity adventure trip,
and I invited Tony to come.
And he came on this trip.
In fact, we opened the book with that story.
And he met all of these
incredible physicians and researchers,
George Church was there, Martine Rothblatt, a multitude.
And he goes all in, he studies.
And so he said, "This is my next book."
He invited me to coauthor it with him,
which had been a joy.
And that's how we got to where (indistinct).
And here we are and you're doing podcasts.
Yeah, exactly.
Let's talk about
some of the other interesting developments
in this space.
Where are we in terms of AI and machine learning
and sensor tech and 3D printing?
Like, how is that going to,
like, at what point can we start to see that
being introduced into our kind of diagnostic regimen?
Yeah, so AI is here now.
AI is out competing physicians almost everywhere
in terms diagnostic.
So AI is diagnosing lung cancer,
prostate cancer, Alzheimer's.
The idea that a human doctor,
as good as we are at pattern recognition
can outdo an AI is getting less and less likely.
In fact, I think it's gonna become malpractice
to diagnose somebody without AI in the loop very soon.
Yeah, when the data sets
as they get larger and larger and larger.
The ability for an AI to detect something
is gonna far exceed the human by capacity.
By a massive margin.
And every hour of the day,
there are probably dozens
if not hundreds of journal articles written.
And in AI can consume all of them.
But no physician can keep up
with the volume of accelerating,
exponentially growing research.
And so AI is here right now.
There's another place that's being used.
One of my companies, my venture friend, Bolds
invested in this called in Silicon medicine,
and a brilliant Russian AI scientist, Alex Krizhevsky
has built this out of Hong Kong
and it's using something called,
Generative Adversarial Networks to design,
which is a type of AI machine learning
to design customized drugs for specific targets.
But it's doing it like a hundred fold faster
and a hundred fold lower cost.
And the eventual where this is eventually gonna go
combining even quantum computing,
'cause quantum chemistry,
looking at predicting how molecules
are interacting with each other
is where I think quantum computing's gonna have
the biggest impact
is we're gonna be able to simulate drugs for you,
specifically for you,
for the surface antigens on your cells
and create drugs N of 1.
And so there's just,
AI is, it's biotech gene therapies, CRISPR,
all of those areas in AI and then sensors.
So today we talked,
we opened with this conversation
that I think we're gonna move the healthcare
out of the office,
out of the hospital, into the home.
And you're gonna have injected sensors subdermally,
you're gonna have sensors you've swallowed,
sensors on your clothing, on your bed, on your hands,
whatever it might be, in your toilet,
that is measuring the parameters all the time.
And passively, uploading it to your AI.
That is constantly, you hop in your autonomous car,
your AI says, listen,
I'm not taking you to the office,
I'm taking you to the office and be gone,
but I'm not taking to where you're going
or going to this center,
'cause I've detected small mRNAs in your bloodstream
that indicates you got an impending cardiac event.
You have this very optimistic perspective on AI.
Your friend, Elon doesn't necessarily
share that optimism.
I mean, it is,
I find myself when you were describing that,
I find myself equal parts fascinated,
but also terrified
of some kind of weaponized dystopian version
of artificial intelligence
and how humanity isn't always so great
about contemplating the unexpected downstream consequences
of some of these technological advances
that were hell bent on.
I mean, we're going to do it no matter what.
Yeah, there's no on off switch,
there's no (indistinct) switch.
But we're not very good about taking a beat
and saying, what are we really doing here?
And how can we enact measures now
in this premature phase
to prevent some of the predictable, negative consequences.
We're actually better than you might think.
So when I was in medical school I remember, recombinant DNA,
the first restriction enzymes
for being able to accurately cut DNA at different locations
came in and it was predicted
to be this disastrous implications for terrorism
and Hitler youth and clone babies.
And it was just like,
front covers of magazines were predicting doom and gloom.
And what happened was that the science community
got together at a place called Asilomar north of here.
And they had the Asilomar conferences
and they created their self-regulatory structures
to preventing these things from happening.
And we haven't had any issues in 40 years.
And the fact of the matter is,
our brains are wired to give much more credence
to negative news than positive news.
Because as we were evolving on the Savannahs of Africa,
you missed a piece of good news, like some food, too bad.
You missed a piece of bad news,
like a rustle in the leaves is a lion and not the wind-
You're dead.
Your Genes are out of the gene pool.
And so we have an ancient piece of our temporal lobe
called the amygdala that scans everything we see
and everything we hear for negative news
and you're glued to it.
And so, I call CNN the "Crisis News Network"
or the "Constantly Negative News Network."
I don't have a good version for Fox.
But we're bombarded by all this negative news,
but it hasn't actually all...
So another thing that we do
is we see a potential piece of bad news out there
and we project it all the way to here
and we're like, we're screwed.
But what we forget
is that we have increasing technologies
that are giving us the resources to solve those problems.
So the environmental disaster of the 1890s,
do you know what it was?
No.
Massive environmental disaster.
Horse shit in the streets.
Yes, horse shit in the streets.
Yeah, exactly right.
People were moving out of the rural area
into the downtown urban area,
they were bringing their emotive force,
the horse with them
and horse shit was piling up every place.
And they redesigned the stoops
to have little runways
so that when it rained,
kind of the shit would flow downhill literally,
but it was causing disease
and the predictions were disastrous.
And what happened, the car came in
and the car displaced the horses
and got rid of that issue.
But it created a bigger problem-
Well, and we're gonna solve that bigger problem.
And I truly believe we are.
We're on the verge of fusion.
If you've been tracking what's going on,
and it's pretty extraordinary.
We're seeing this year,
we're gonna create more photoable take,
electric capacity in the United States
than any other form
of over half of the US electric.
New electricity production is gonna be a affordable take.
And we're seeing amazing progress on batteries.
And I just had incredible conversation
with a team out of Google on zero-point energy,
but I won't go there too, its another conversation.
Well, there was that news item the other day.
I didn't read past the headlines,
but that nuclear fusion machine
that creates infinite energy.
What is that about?
So I think that's, it's really the fusion work
that's going on right now.
So there's about, I would've never thanked this,
but there's like a dozen VC-backed fusion companies.
And this is harnessing the power of the sun,
which creates no radioactive waste.
But is able to provide a massive abundance of energy.
And so the prediction and I talk about this in my books
that we're heading
towards a squanderble abundance of energy.
And interestingly enough,
we're moving very rapidly in solar
and solar and wind, incredible progress.
The poorest countries in the world
are the sunniest countries in the world.
They may become net energy exporters,
and then we may see fusion coming in
and displacing all of that.
So not, I'm not sure how we got onto this conversation, but.
Well, the idea of being optimistic about the future,
I was sort of challenging you
with a dystopian counterpoint,
but I think, yeah,
it's this Stephen Pinker idea
of life is actually a lot better than you think.
And we have this tendency to look in the past
and think that it was a lot rosy (indistinct) was.
We romanticised the past
and it was short and brutish
and you died at 40 from TB.
Honestly, the poorest people amongst us today
are living better than the Kings and Queens did.
It just, we compare ourselves against our neighbors
and we compare ourselves against people we don't even know.
And we forget, it's like,
we don't look at how far we've come.
We look at sort of this potential perfection.
But it's amazing what we have access to.
Well, certainly to ponder the viability
of printing organs or just the rudimentary implications
of VR headsets on medical students
who could put themselves in the position
of performing cutting edge surgeries,
that they wouldn't be able to bear witness to,
like all of the learning tools that are now available,
certainly in the sensory tech
that would allow us to have interventions
at a very early phase.
Like these are all fantastic things.
But then I read like this idea
about bringing the woolly mammoth back to-
Yeah, I love it.
So like-
I love it.
And I'm like, all right,
well, this is right out of the script
of any bad sci-fi movie idea of humans gone wrong.
(Peter laughing) Or is it?
So we have caused huge extinction events of our own
and is it bad to bring back an extinct species?
Not all, we can stop short
of the T-Rexs and the Velociraptors
but the woolly mammoth, the sabertooth tiger, the dodo,
whatever it is,
interestingly enough,
I'm an investor and an advisor to colossal the company
full disclosure, that's doing that.
Ben Lamb is a brilliant CEO,
it's backed by George Church.
It's been one of his pet projects
and also bringing back extinct plants
that are important for our environment.
So I think the tech isn't bad,
it's the use of the tech that can go wrong.
And so do we have the wisdom to be able to do that?
Yeah, it's a broader conversation
around the distinction between knowledge and wisdom.
Yes.
And I think historically, humanity has told us that
that we're pretty good at knowledge
and maybe not so good at wisdom all the time.
It's interesting, an interesting thought recently,
I'll share with you,
if you asked, what is the definition of wisdom?
I think I would pause it and tell me what you think
that wisdom is having enough experience,
having seen things enough
to be able to see unintended consequences
and to make a decision based upon better judgment.
Is that fair?
Yeah, I think that's fair.
So if that's true,
I think one of the biggest opportunities
for increasing wisdom is gonna be AI simulations,
because you can imagine building out AI systems
that can try millions or billions of variants
of a situation.
And then 'cause simulations are getting so much better.
We can talk about living in a simulation if you want.
But the idea that an AI can give us
a views towards unintended consequences,
that we might not be able to fathom in our own minds.
What's your take on AI reaching its own escape velocity
and becoming self-aware and self-improving,
extending beyond the controllable black box?
Yeah, so I think it,
I don't have any question that it will happen.
Our brains are neural nets.
Our brains, and we are extending more and more and more.
And we're building chipsets that look and feel
like the neural nets of a brain.
And we're seeing all the progress this last five years
has been this massive increase in AI.
And that's a result of more computation and more data.
And we've got companies like open AI,
that's produced GPT-3 and now GPT-4 and deep mind,
which is part of alphabet.
And they're moving at a prodigious rate.
Ray Cowell's prediction to go back to his predictions
are that we'll see human level AI by 2029,
and he's still sticking with it.
And that means the next year it'll be super human.
So the question is, what do you do at that point?
And one of the ideas that I'm enamored with
and Elon is funding is we're gonna merge humanity with it.
And this is the whole realm of brain computer interface
that we're gonna,
our brains have a hundred billion neurons,
a hundred trillion synaptic connections
that are shaped everything you hear.
But our brains are limited in their capacity.
You can't grow the brain any bigger.
Otherwise, you can get through the birth canal.
And in fact, what our brain ended up doing
to increase the neocortex, the upper layers,
it started creating these folds that you see
to increase the surface area.
So when we use our phones
and we want to do a complicated image analysis
or voice analysis,
that computation doesn't happen on the phone.
The phone gathers the data from the camera,
the speakers, and so forth.
And it sends the data to the edge of the cloud
on a 4G or 5G network.
And the processing gets done there.
And then the answer comes back to your phone.
So what does that look like?
For a human brain,
imagine if you could think, like ask the question,
what's the GDP of Ghana?
And have the data from that question
transmitted to the cloud and Google
by thinking and get the answer back.
So that technology is, we're there it's the next few years.
There's Neurolink, which is Elon's company,
I'm an advisor in a company called Paradromics
and an investor and advisor in another company
called Openwater.
All of these are brain computer interface companies.
And Ray's prediction again,
'cause there are a few things that he's put out there
is that by the early to mid 2030s,
we're gonna have high bandwidth brain computer interface.
Again, can't slow down.
What do you do with it?
And where's the wisdom-based star chamber for all of this?
Like that's my concern.
I get it, I understand.
I mean, it's fascinating to think about
it's certainly maturing to the point
of becoming a conceptual reality
and it makes you wonder
whether or not humanity exists
like on this evolutionary path
to give birth to this greater life form
in the sort Chrysalis of caterpillar to butterfly.
Yeah, I think-
And what does that mean for humanity?
And where does humanity's hubris sit in all of this
and thinking that this is beneficial at best
and at worst innocuous.
Do you want to go there?
My last chapter, my last book was on that topic.
I know, and again, ever the optimist.
Yeah, so I think that this notion
of brain computer interface
is going to be the transition point for our metamorphosis,
our transformation.
If you look back at the history of life on this planet,
our planet was formed four and a half billion years ago,
about half a billion years after that,
the earliest life forms on this planet came into existence
are called prokaryotic cells.
They were very simple bags of cytoplasm
with free floating DNA in them.
About a half a billion to a billion years after that
give or take,
those single cell prokaryotic life forms evolved
into eukaryotic life forms.
All ceded of course by aliens.
No, I'm not gonna go there.
No, I Know, I'm just...
But these eukaryotic life forms
effectively were these early life forms
with incorporated technology into them.
So the eukaryotic lifeforms had ingested
what are we call now mitochondria, which were energy plants.
They were other bacteria
that had able to do oxidative energy production.
And so they ingested that as a power plant
inside of the cell,
then endoplasmic reticulum for creating proteins
and golgi apparatus and more importantly a nuclear membrane
and chromosomal structures.
And so we went from a simple life form
to a more complicated single cell life form
with technology as part of it.
The next phase a billion years later,
was to go from single cell to multicellular life forms
where these cells would come together collaboratively
and work together, eventually forming you and me.
We have 40 trillion cells in our body, give or take,
we're not a single life form.
We're a collaboration of 40 trillion cells.
And so when I think about that,
I think about the analogies today
that we as humans are the prokaryotic life,
the very simple individual.
And we're in the midst of incorporating technology
into ourselves, right?
Like going from prokaryotic to eukaryotic life
where these mobile phones are part of us.
It's my memory bank is here and such.
And as we start to connect.
And if Rich,
I have a BCI connection and you do as well,
and I can share thoughts with you,
it's a level of connection and intimacy like watching,
I can watch the sun rising in Tokyo
through the eyes of somebody.
There's a level of connectedness
that I think is extraordinary.
And just like you wouldn't take a knife and stab your arm
'cause it's you.
Imagine a world in which we're so connected
that I want you to succeed as much as you possibly can
because you're success is my success.
That level of a transformation.
So I call that a meta intelligence level.
Again, this is best done with a glass wine or a scotch,
but I mean, there's some interesting directions ahead.
Yeah, I mean, I hope it would move in that direction.
I mean, my sense is that the early days of the internet,
there was a similar conversation
around how connectivity would breed empathy
and bring us closer together.
But I don't have to tell you,
all you gotta do is scroll on Twitter
and realize that sort of semi-utopian notion
has not really been delivered upon.
But it has delivered on a multitude of other benefits.
Yeah, of course I would concede that, yeah.
And I wanna talk,
so let's talk about education
'cause I think you have some really interesting thoughts
around that.
And that's an area where,
I think most people agree we're in dire need
of a re-imagination.
And we now have at our best,
these incredibly powerful technological tools
that I think really have so many beneficial applications.
There are two industries I want to help topple,
healthcare and education.
Both of them are just in extremists.
Both of them are doing us a disservice,
and both can be reinvented.
AI is gonna be at the core of both.
When you think about that Google
for the wealthiest child on the planet
and the poorest child on the planet, is identical.
Larry Page's son has access to the same Google
that my son has.
If everybody has a tablet,
then they can tap into what's available.
Yes, and the cost of tablets have dropped below 40 bucks
in using Android devices and such.
So it is, and there'll be a point at which,
I can imagine Amazon or Facebook
giving every kid a tablet
to have access to eventual buying power
from that child.
So we're getting
to global bandwidth connectivity
and devices are eventually demonetizing to zero.
The overall structure of education
being what it is right now,
which is really a legacy
of the outside of the industrial revolution.
And we really have not iterated upon that
in any meaningful way of sense.
Agreed, agreed.
What I was saying was Google is the same,
it's complete democratization and demonetization.
And I think we're gonna reach a point.
I'm sure we'll reach a point
where the best healthcare is gonna be AI-enabled,
which will be accessible to the poorest and the wealthiest.
And it will be the same education will be AI-enabled
where an AI knows your child's favorite sports star,
movie star.
Are they auditory learner or a visual learner
and be able to create a personalized level of education
for that individual.
Now we're gonna need to differentiate
between cognitive learning and social learning.
But where we're going with Web3
and the ability for AI to deliver.
I mean, I have two, 10 and a half year old boys
and they love Roblox.
It's like their religion.
And they would play Roblox almost all the time
if given permission.
And it's sad that education isn't like that,
why don't we have educational games?
And when you're in school,
you start with a score of a hundred percent.
And every time you get something wrong,
your score goes down.
In the gaming world,
you start with zero and every time you get something right,
your score goes up.
Why doesn't that exist?
Why can't we connect to the game mechanics
of the human brain to do that?
And I think we can.
Well, it's also architectured around rote memorization
of facts and testing.
Yes.
Which is ludicrous.
Yes, I mean, it's as you said,
it's all supporting the creation of workers
from the industrial revolution.
And that's what we needed.
We needed people who followed instructions.
The bell would ring in the classroom,
you're on your production line.
You go to the next place to stop your brain with something.
And I think we need to reinvent.
I mean, for me,
it's reinventing education around passion driven.
It's like, what is your passion and your purpose?
I love the Mark Twain quote,
"There're two important days in your life,
"the day that you're born
"and the day that you find out why."
So helping kids first find out why,
and then how to structure an argument,
how to provide a compelling point of view
and how to lead, how to have grit.
Perseverance, grit, curiosity.
Curiosity, fundamental,
asking great questions.
All of these things, I think like,
you look at a young person
and when they're self-directed, enthusiastic, curious
and already have a sense of what lights them up
like that kid's gonna be fine.
Yes, exactly.
But not all kids are wired that way
or are not in environments or circumstances
that lend themselves towards development
of those soft skills.
I mean, you're somebody who at a very early age,
you have this complete obsession with space.
I was lucky Apollo.
But that is, on some level that is luck.
It is luck.
'Cause not everybody gets struck with something
that they can carry through their entire life.
Yes, yeah.
No, I agree with you.
It was luck.
It was Apollo showed me what was possible,
and then as I like to say,
that scientific documentary "Star Trek"
showed me where things were going.
You and me, both, I love that.
Yeah, yeah.
(Rich laughing)
And it-
I went to "Star Trek" conventions when I was a kid.
Love it.
And yeah, so how do you help kids experience enough
to find their true passion that becomes a purpose,
and then they learn to fulfill those desires?
So in the case of your own kids
and being a dad, a parent,
I mean, are your kids in traditional school?
Are they homeschooled?
Like how are you injecting their lives
with all of these ideas that you're passionate about?
Yeah, so they're in a traditional private school
and it was interesting
we only found one school that we liked and I was like, okay,
they don't get in
'cause it's twin white Caucasian boys.
And the probability of getting in was relatively low.
It was like, I'm gonna start a school
if I can't get them in.
And they did get in.
And I still am thinking about starting a school.
Doesn't Elon have,
does he still have that add extra school?
I went to go and to visit high school
and it was a sort of like a third through eighth grade.
And then when his kids ended up graduating, he stopped it.
It was on the campus of SpaceX.
And it was fantastic and I love what they were doing.
So for example, one of the things
that head of the school who was a brilliant guy did,
is he created these interesting experiments.
He said, okay, here's a town,
and it's on the edge of a lake.
And the town has a factory
and all of the employees are either employed by the factory
or there are fishermen in the lake
and the fish feed the town,
and we're gonna create representation
in our school of the fisheries, the factory,
the government and the public.
And all of a sudden,
one day it's found out that the factory
is polluting and killing the fish in the lake,
play different roles and play it out.
So it's that kind of thinking that kind of debate
and discussion, critical thinking
that I think is so important.
Yeah, my sense is,
and this is just my own and of one experience
is that at least in Los Angeles,
there's plenty of interesting experiments
in education for kids at the earlier stages,
like in the younger grades.
But at some point, these things all kind of fall apart
once the kids are 12, 14, 15 year old,
and there aren't any schools
that carry it through the conclusion of high school
and maybe that's because parents get scared
or they wanna make sure,
while everyone else is doing it this way,
like this is too radical and they freak out
while at the same time we are seeing
an explosion in homeschooling.
Yeah, agreed.
And this COVID definitely was interesting situation.
Well, I mean, everybody on Zoom said it's disaster.
Yeah, total disaster.
One of the big questions then
is college gonna be a thing in a decade?
I think I grew up a lot in college socially.
Had my sufficient amount of being picked on and such.
And I learned how to defend myself mentally
and got onto my own where you're outside.
So that's really important that those years
of 18 to 24, there about.
But I think beyond that,
the freedom to go and learn,
but I don't use anything I learned in college, do you?
No, no.
I mean, we grew up in a time where
if you wanted to be successful in the world,
you had to go to college and possibly grad school.
I don't think that that is the case today.
Certainly for the reasons you stated,
I think it's a wonderful experience to have,
but it's not necessarily for everybody now.
And nor should it be.
I think ultimately, college is a shorthand
oh, that person went to Princeton
or that person went to Stanford, so they're smart.
It's a social validation stamp.
Yeah, but there are other ways,
I mean, some of the stuff that Peter Thiel was doing,
like I'll pay you to drop outta college.
I remember Elon having a hackathon
and tweeting out that "I don't care
"if you graduated high school or not.
"If you're a great programmer, I'll hire you."
And I think that's gonna be an interesting direction
of can you find your passion?
And then can you partner with the technology
that helps you develop your passion?
And then do what you love to do.
'cause a lot of people get a job
not because it's their passion
it's because that's how they get food on the table
or get their clothing for their family.
Yeah, I mean, passion is an indulgence for most people.
But with respect to your own kids,
like how are you outside of the formal schooling construct,
trying to help them
discover their passion, cultivate curiosity,
develop grit and perseverance and all of these qualities.
I state publicly,
and I've written a few blogs on the subject
that there are three things I want for them
that are, it's not about AI, robotics,
or any of those things.
It's, I want them to find their passion.
I want them to learn to ask great questions,
and I want them to develop grit, perseverance.
I think those are the three most.
And then to be great friends
since they're fraternal twins.
And passion is a matter of just exposing them
to as much stuff as possible.
I had kids when I was 50,
and so I'm lucky in that I can like,
nope, not going there to work today,
I'm gonna go and do this.
And it's not possible for everybody.
But I have an unlimited budget for books for the kids.
It's like, whatever book you wanna buy,
a hundred percent just ask me,
Amazon will deliver it tomorrow.
Asking great question has become sort of a joke
'cause every day I drop 'em off at school,
I would say, ask great questions today.
What questions did you ask today?
And became sort of an annoyance.
And then perseverance and grit,
we've sort of created a family motto
that the kids have developed that we don't give up.
Right, and with the advent of AI and machine learning
and all of that,
obviously we're ushering in this era of automation
where so many jobs are gonna become obsolete.
Like how do you think about their future
and where you would direct your kids to,
not be a victim of this new world order
that it's soon to be.
It's a fascinating question.
So one realization is technology is constantly changing,
but a lot of the problems are not.
And so can you become an expert in a problem
and really understand it
and then be in a position to apply
whatever the technology dejo is to that problem.
I think there's some real truth in that element.
Folks who have kids in a high school today or college,
biotech and AI are the two fields that for the time being
are gonna be employing people
and it's like get that degree
and you've gotta job instantly.
And then ultimately, we are demonetizing living.
And the question is,
are we going to separate working for income
and working for fun?
So there's in the Web3 world,
there's a platform called Axie Infinity.
I dunno if you've ever heard of it?
So it's a game that's called a play to earn.
So people who play the game are making money.
And in parts of Asia and Vietnam, Thailand and so forth,
people are earning their living
playing this game, Axie Infinity.
And I'm not gonna be say, I understand it,
or I fully believe it, you have to buy into it,
and then as you're playing the game,
you're developing your characters
and you're selling 'em to other people
who want to enter the game and so forth.
So there's, whether it's a Ponzi scheme or not,
but there is the tokenization of our world
is going to change how and where we earn our living.
It's so strange.
I mean, that's a larger conversation
about the hearkening of the metaverse.
And when I look at what's happening
with the tokenization and the NFT world,
like this is just an initial baby step into-
It's a baby step.
Us, this economy that will exist in the virtual space
and our relationship between our real lives
and the lives that will transpire there.
And like, maybe I'm just too old,
but like you're again, the optimist here,
and I've tried so hard to learn about
aspects of that.
And I really struggle.
Yeah, and I think it's the only way to learn
is by doing and playing and experiencing.
And so I'm trying to do that as much as I can
and it is fascinating.
I can see enough promise over the horizon.
I'm in Bitcoin and Ethereum,
I've not bought a single NFT.
I'm still not a believer,
even though my friends have made millions of dollars
in the world,
it's like, nah, just not there.
I believe NFTs are gonna be important
for a number of business reasons.
Just not there on the board (indistinct).
But the Web3 where Web2 was a web of information exchange
and Web3 is gonna be a value exchange
where I can be transmitting money to you,
or transmitting ownership of things to you instantly
is massive.
It's a hundred times maybe a thousand fold
more massive than the current web is today.
Well, the idea of smart contracts
and just the ease with which,
we're gonna be able to kind of conduct business
and create incentives, et cetera,
all the way down the line with that
I think is really interesting.
It's an amazing time.
And then you start to realize the kinds of things
you can monetize.
So a few companies I know about
if you sequence your genome
and if you give them access to your genome
to be used in different product developments and so forth,
you can earn money from it and such.
If your genome is used for creating a discovery
and so forth.
My head's gonna explode.
Yeah, I mean, honestly,
it's the only constant is change
and the speed of change is increasing.
Now I am the optimist
and I feel like optimism is warranted
over and over and over again over the last 50 years.
And our tools,
I define an entrepreneur
as someone who finds a juicy problem and fixes it.
That's what real entrepreneurs are doing well.
And I also believe that the world's biggest problems
are the world's biggest business opportunities.
And when I teach at Singularity University
and Abundance360,
is I wanna become a billionaire to help a billion people.
There's those kinds of mantras and mindsets that are like,
where can I go solve this problem?
What problem can I go solve there?
Yeah, on the mindset piece,
I think that's really important.
And maybe this is the last thing that we can cover here.
When I look at the breadth of your work,
you're somebody who has never been afraid
to tackle big problems
and really set what most would assume
to be just outlandish, audacious goals.
So it's that relationship...
There's a certain kind of like relationship to reality
that you have and possibility.
Like why advocate for incremental change
when you can say we're gonna do X, Y, or Z
that nobody had ever thought of?
So talk to me a little bit about-
Yeah, happily.
You're thinking around that.
So I think mindset is the single most important thing
that anyone can take out of this conversation today
in addition to health.
I got religion on mindset over the course of the last decade
and I've made it the focus.
So I mentor thousands of entrepreneurs
through an abundance digital,
and I run a CEO executive program year round
called Abundance360,
which is part of Singularity University.
And I've focused the entire programmer on mindset.
And there are four mindsets that I focus on,
an abundance mindset, an exponential mindset,
a moonshot mindset, and a longevity mindset.
There's gratitude mindsets,
and curiosity mindsets,
come back to the primaries.
If I were to ask you what made Steve Jobs, Jeff Bezos,
Elon Musk, Mahatma Gandhi, whoever it might be successful.
Was it the money they had?
Was it the relationships they had?
Was it the tech they had?
Or was it their mindset?
I would pause that that mindset
is the most important out of those things.
If you took away everything from them,
but they maintained their mindset,
they would regain some portion of it.
And so if that's true, if mindset is that important,
then where are we proactively developing
and honing our mindsets?
'Cause most of us including me
until this last decade
have been getting our mindsets from our parents or schools,
God forbid, the stuff we watch on TV.
And instead of like proactively honing it.
And so let me, if you don't mind,
let me hit on those four mindsets.
Absolutely.
So abundance mindset is something I got that
out of Singularity University
and it got me to write my first book,
"Abundance: The Future Is Better Than You Think."
And it was the realization that, oh my God,
we are moving from scarcity,
which is we're genetically dialed into scarcity.
We have in our brains, in our genome,
we have a scarcity mindset because it was where we evolved.
But technology is a force that turns
whatever used to be scarce into abundance
over and over and over again.
Case in point we used to go and kill whales
to get whale oil to light our Knight,
That we ravaged mountainsides for coal.
Then we drill kilometers in the ocean floor
and now affordable takes, we talked about fusion.
There's a squanderble abundance of energy coming.
So tech moved it from scarcity to abundance.
We have more capital year on year on year
than any time ever.
So we're gonna hit a hundred trillion
in our global economy this year.
We've hit the most number of unicorns ever.
The amount of venture capital invested in 2017,
beat 2016, 2018 beat 2017,
even on and on and on.
Even through the pandemic.
This 2021, we doubled the amount of venture capital
done in 2020, which doubled 2019.
Okay, let's go on this past year.
What would you think of as is more scarce
than a perfect diamond of four carat
five Carat, 10 Carat diamond?
Pandora, the largest jeweler on the planet this past year
said, we're gonna stop selling conflict diamonds
or mine diamonds that have social issues
and we're only gonna produce manufactured diamonds.
And so all of a sudden diamonds went from being scarce
to perfect diamonds,
8, 10, 20 Carat diamonds becoming abundant.
It's the cost of electricity, methane and water.
And a friend of mine at the company
called the Diamond Foundry Manufacturers,
whatever gem you want,
do you want flowers and perfections, you can do that.
And so this is an abundance mindset
which I'll cap that went off in the following way.
If you got a pie and all of a sudden,
twice as many people show up for dinner
in a scarcity mindset,
you're like, ah damn, I gotta slice,
the slice is thinner and thinner and thinner.
In an abundance mindset, it's bullshit,
we're gonna bake more pies.
That's an abundance mindset.
Every year, it's giving us more and more opportunities,
which has been fundamentally the case.
Your competition, forget about them.
There's more opportunities,
let's go and go in that direction.
An exponential mindset is just the notion
that we're linear thinkers, take 30 linear steps.
You're 30 meters away,
but our tech world is growing exponentially 30 doublings.
One, two, four, eight, 16, 32.
And 30 doublings, you're a billion meters away.
You've gone around the planet 26 times.
And so in an exponential mindset,
it's important to be able
to see where the technologies are going
and how they're converging.
And so at a 360 that I work people
through the abundance mindset,
give the examples of increasing abundance
across almost every single area,
exponential mindsets and what the implications are.
A moonshot mindset is the notion that most of the world
would love 10%,
would really love a 10% improvement,
in revenues, 10% more customers.
And that's a great stretch goal.
In a moonshot mindset,
you're saying, no, no, no.
I don't want 10%.
I want to go 10 times bigger, a thousand percent bigger.
And when you do that,
you've gotta let go of all your preconceived notions.
The Astro Teller who's the captain of moonshot said
alphabet, a brilliant guy,
a friend who I care about greatly
gives an example that says,
if you're a car company
and your car is doing 50 miles per gallon
and you want to get to 55, you can do that.
You can lightweight the car, get bear at aerodynamics.
But if you want to go from 50 to 500,
you've gotta start with a clean sheet of paper,
and reinvent the car.
And so the ability to take these moonshots are here
because of these exponential technologies.
And when I'm teaching the CEOs that I coach,
it's like, you want to keep 95% of your company doing 10%.
They're generating the engine,
that keeps you alive
and you don't want them taking moonshots.
But you wanna find that small team,
that moonshot team and take them away from the main company.
And you wanna say to them,
listen, I don't want you taking 10%.
If I see you doing 10% activities, you're fired,
I want you trying crazy ideas
that are the potential to reinvent our business.
The day before something is really a breakthrough,
it's a crazy idea.
And most companies aren't trying crazy ideas.
And then they're stuck in incrementalism.
Yeah, the idea of creating a skunk works
within each company.
'Cause every company,
when it reaches a certain scale
falls prey to its own bureaucracy
and soon becomes a dinosaur
short of having that level of innovation within,
which requires a very a certain focus.
A few hundred year old companies.
The final mindset that I'm enamored with
and it's what gave birth to this book, "Life Force"
to bring it back is the longevity mindset.
And if you can will yourself to death
and you can will yourself to live longer,
if you have something to live for.
And if you believe you have the ability
to live out of pain
and have the cognition, the aesthetics, the mobility.
And so a longevity mindset for me
is helping people see where this field is going.
One of the things I did, Rich
was I built over the last year an AI engine
that searches the global news,
journals, tweets, magazines, newspapers,
and it finds longevity in health tech breakthroughs.
And it scans it for any dystopian.
And it rates in on a quality article.
And I get a digest every day
it uses GPT3, uses the open AI's AI engine
to gimme a summary paragraph
about 15 different breakthroughs per day.
And so it's my longevity mindset.
I'm seeing what's going on in all of these different fields.
And I have zero question
about reaching longevity escape velocity,
and you can try it as can everyone else.
It's free.
It's longevityinsider.org.
And at the end of the day,
I get this news that gives me tremendous hope.
And because of that,
I'm willing to change my diet, sleep longer,
I do intermittent fasting.
Right, it's almost,
we're the last generation,
who are like,
patting right up against the edge
of whether we'll make it across the transom or not
which is interesting.
Well, it was a pleasure talking to you.
Oh, lot of fun conversations, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I hope that the utopian version of all the things
that you are speaking about comes to fruition.
And if Skynet should befall us, I'm gonna call you up.
All right, I'll be watching for it.
And I'd love to have you back
whenever you want to talk about space
and all these other things that that you're into,
'cause it's super fascinating.
But I appreciate you coming here today.
The book is "Life Force" available wherever you buy books.
A great primer to read in conjunction
with David Sinclair's fantastic book, "Lifespan."
And there's a lot of stuff in there
that'll blow your mind.
So thank you.
Thank you, Rich, appreciate you.
Peace.
(bright upbeat music)